medical soul is back will jimmy mcgill
finally be undone by his web of lies and
manipulation and if so will he take kim
down with him
it's been a long two years but better
call seoul is back for its sixth and
final season and we're here to break
down everything that happens
the first episode of better call saul
season 6 is like a slow burning wick
steadily inching toward dynamite we
don't see as some of the consequences
from the season 5 finale just yet but
it's clear that explosions are imminent
what was saul goodman and kim wexler
setting up their plan for revenge
against howard hamlin by planting drugs
in his country club locker there's also
the matter of nacho going on the run
from the cartels as well as lalo
tracking nacho down while allowing
everyone to believe he's dead after the
events of the season 5 finale everyone's
lives and livelihoods hang in the
balance in the two-part premieres second
episode carrot and stick and an
explosive final season is well underway
it's a good thing amc saw fit to provide
us the season's first two hours back to
back revenge has been a common theme
throughout better corsol and season 6
episode 1 really goes all in on that
idea sarl and kim want revenge against
howard while lalo seeks retribution
against those who tried to kill him
but the question remains where will
their quest for revenge leave them
better call seoul fans are in for a
blast from the past in carrot and stick
seoul pays a visit to craig and betsy
cattlemen who have not been seen since
the show's first season when they were
accused of embezzlement the plotline
ultimately ended with craig taking the
fall and going to jail apparently he's
out now and he and his wife are running
a rinky-dink attacks prep outfit saul
uses the kettlemans and a false promise
that they can clear craig's name by
telling them a story detailing how
howard hamlin was under the influence of
drugs when he represented craig they go
around town spreading the rumor that
howard's on drugs but without any
concrete evidence no lawyer will take
the case still soul's done his job the
rumors out there sol and kim returned to
the kettleman by the episode's end and
they're understandably angry seoul
offers them cash to get them to drop the
case but they don't go down quietly it's
at this point that kim calls an
associate who can take the kettlemans
down once again for tax fraud
okay
enough carrot
not wanting to go down that route again
they give up surprisingly the episode
implies that kim has broken bad even
more than saul at this point saul was
more than happy to offer them hush money
but kim threatens their very livelihoods
even saul's taken her back by the move
and he still winds up giving them the
cash if kim was willing to threaten the
kettlemans how far might she be willing
to go to enact her revenge on howard
nacho thinks he's safe when he checks
into the motel in the first episode of
season six all he has to do is hide and
wait but in a world where everyone is
looking for him his discovery is
inevitable it doesn't take long for the
salamanca cousins and their crew to
stumble upon him and the result is an
all-out shootout in the vicinity at
first it appears that a lot of the crew
members don't care if they bring him in
dead or alive but one of the cousins is
quick to shoot one of their own
accomplices telling another crew member
vivo meaning they want him alive after
his perceived slighter games to
salamanca family why would they want him
back alive it all goes back to the
season 6 premier episode hector
salamanca told lalo that if he was going
to adequately avenge his honor by
attacking gus frink he needed proof that
gerst was actually behind the attack the
only person they have at their disposal
who could feasibly turn on gus would be
nacho so they need him alive at least
for the time being who knows what
nacho's fate beyond that will be he
doesn't appear at all in breaking bad so
things don't exactly look promising
after we see nacho get apprehended by
the salamancas there's a scene involving
a meeting between gus tyrus and mike
gertz is now aware that lalo is still
alive
so they need to go on the defensive to
make it out alive as usual mike's cool
calm and collected he knows the game
better than anyone and he explains that
lalo isn't going to come after him
unless he has a good reason to naturally
if nacho squeals that'd be all the
evidence lalu needs to pin the
assassination attempt on gus and go
after him it could start an all-out turf
war between the cartels gus sings
strategically so mike's the only one
actually looking out for nacho's
well-being and when gus brings up
getting nacho's father mike is adamantly
against this he doesn't want to bring
innocence into their twisted game and
almost causes mike to lose his head
fortunately nacho calls him right there
and then as we know nacho's already been
captured it's unclear what conversation
will unfold from the call but one
possibility is that it will involve
nacho trying to get gus to confess to
ordering the hit
it's a deadly game of cat and mouse and
things won't stay so quiet for long
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one